welcome to this video I'm playing
international massive step by step from
Bulgaria I don't think nope yeah I had
checked this and he does not have the
name in them let's see this laugh line
that are playing quite often let's see
what he has prepared most people play
Bishop g4 nowadays really it's a bit
more bit more interesting than Bishop f5
oh that's an early capture aha sorry
place he placed this a little bit like a
goon felt okay yeah I probably should
just take the center f5 this Knight b6
we play play this prep move okay so he's
not minding here a queen trade hmm also
have Bishop c4
unclear I mean unclear what it's not
clear to me how I should play maybe this
is also a possibility attacking f7 and
allowing me to recapture with the bishop
should here take on b3
e 6 yeah this is a sort of asking for it
we should take these six so could this
be enough for white take selfie queen
takes Bishop e7 e five this is type of
stuff that's also night f8 and now this
is probably probably nonsense for white
I mean let's just develop him
hmm and now the capture is is more
interesting oh come on let's let's let's
go for that Jack King every other know
if I've or not isn't this just what am i
overlooking here Quinn be too is this
the point or the problem okay on a night
move i just take d7 and win this maybe
it's really Quint XP to hear the problem
okay so what am i what what do i need to
do here the snide hangs probably
probably i need to Castle all right and
I have some I need to cancel here c3 is
hanging was checking at him on as well
so and now taking here this is an
interesting moment if he recaptures with
the night I have the idea to play rook c
1 and D Phi it with Bishop c5 being very
dangerous armed Roxy one Queen somewhere
and d5 threatening Bishop c5 and over
this is very dangerous definitely yes
okay
let's do it and d5 next rook e8 I can
give the check win the Queen so d5 what
is this move against this really I don't
see it really what's the other na other
rock more precise maybe I was taking us
time yeah this was of course I mean I
didn't plan plan that I'll be fine but
it somehow working out I believe at
least I have at the moment I don't see
any defense against this not really okay
this must be right anyway b6 maybe but
this this should at least give me a
substantial attack of course I is
covering this discovering d6 year with
the Queen ah I see so that means this
means he is not directly directly mated
him
maybe the other look was also more
precisely i think i think i need to do
this now it's not that's not perfect my
okay one is unprotected maybe 97 was
impossible but he played and played
instant moves okay 7 I need to get in
there with the rooks
yeah this this with tempo is both worth
something um this one tending hook f700
d7 look I can take is six so look a 6
may be on time morning okay sixth is not
threaten much which I maybe you can give
this checks to the checks IAM check so
that at the end i will i will get to get
age 7 now the sea polar the sea pawn and
i also thought i would get the Jeep on
but I don't this is a big problem check
check maybe this is saving me the day
here with hook h5 rook edge form he
wants to knock ok this is of course
something that you can do
check is found found a way to continue
this is really really good c3 King d3
okay i think i will save the draw him
yeah I have no it'll wait to do anything
with the points yet they are just too
weak check check yet so it's really a
bit I almost pointless but ok we can
play a couple of Momus check check gain
draw yeah Wow tough tough stuff I don't
know I don't know I've been some way
some way to win this the other look
maybe I don't know computer wants to go
Bishop f4 instead haha I didn't see that
at all Bishop f4 is a typical case of
violating the candidate new principle of
course this comes into consideration
what happens after this Jack [ __ ] gives
us the best slider maybe it always
should be some sort of Perpetual but
what about this ruki aid is winning yeah
check probably
the this this he played this very
quickly and the discovery is other
problem here and black wins this was my
suspicions he played this very quickly
Queenie a king his home or in 97 I met
take but this is winds just to walk
saying yeah so this was the big hole in
the in the end concept and after this EP
probably also should win but it is it is
tricky night d5 now King c7m okay there
are probably a small and having more
than one way to get probably even here
it is a win the sea point is so
dangerous that there should be some some
precise way to win check up to this
point the compressor giving black still
the win maybe a night f6 here was much
stronger yep okay this just picks up the
pond I seem okay yeah this was channel
all in all a very lucky result check
yeah I'm check annoying with the rook at
least so yeah here it is a drawn I mean
now not really i mean i can't play for
win here probably with a form at least
try I mean I cannot lose anymore as I
can always get rid of the porn on c3 but
okay I have 12 seconds it's probably not
very realistic I was glad to do to get
the porn of the board to have a draw
secured yeah a tough game thanks for
watching